hi Brian you asked what is what is the
most interesting idea I've heard today
and where the lot of professors from
Harvard University told me about
algorithmic corporations and today we
can do that with cloud computing we can
have an algorithm that spins up servers
and then makes new resources available
to a system well he's talking about
doing that with the legal instrument
that generates a corporation that I've
algorithm will say we need a new company
and we'll spin up all the legal
documents and file them and create an
LLC why would you do that because one
thing I've heard several times today
here at Davos is that companies are now
facturing themselves so that they can
take more investors without going public
and without disclosing their financial
results to the public do the SEC rules
so here we could have an algorithmic
setting that could say well we've taken
too many investors let's start another
company and spin up a new company that
does something a little bit different
but associated with the main company
it's a really interesting idea and I
think your second question is what keeps
me motivated I just the interesting
ideas and where the future of technology
as I go around the world and interview
people and put that up on my youtube
channel at stabilizer youtube com so I'm
Scott wiser and I have hundreds of
interviews and I'm always wanted to find
the next interesting idea